c'est une fronde historique que personne
n'a vu venir en france
elle allait rallier des centaines de
milliers de français dont ornella la
mère célibataire c'est tout de suite
reconnu dans une colère qui allait
sortir de l'ombre du monde virtuel des
réseaux sociaux pour éclater sur les
routes de campagne autour des ronds
points et sur les grandes avenues de
paris
[Applaudissements]
je suis ni gilet jaune
je suis pas né à la bonne époque où dans
une société une société qui ne
correspond pas à l'origine ces prix de
l'essence à la pompe en augmentation
constante qui sème un vent de
mécontentement
rapidement c'est un orage qui s'abat sur
une partie de la france
un orage qui va durer ou le ras-le-bol
est hélas la goutte d'eau de carburant
qu'après les gens se sont mis à parler
se sont dévoilés sur les ronds-points ou
dans les cabanes donc ont appris qu'ils
n'étaient pas seuls à en chier beaucoup
de gens ont réalisé que quand il faisait
leur leurs calculs qui à la fin du mois
il restait pas grand chose n'hésitez pas
les seuls
on est là dit avoir fait le choix de la
pauvreté elle n'a pour seul revenu que
le rsa le revenu solidaire actif une
forme d' aides sociales
cette intersection de ces en normandie
ce jour-là on trouve de tout une
fonctionnaire à la retraite petits
commerçants
un jeune qui convoite un avenir en
politique et steve un enseignant de
langue anglaise bonjour au niveau des 16
pour steve le combat du gilet jaune
c'est celui d'une france des campagnes
que l'on voit plus dans les métropoles
ignoré des élites et des politiciens et
tous bords les hôpitaux y avait de moins
en moins les tribunaux il y en a de
moins en moins les trésoreries gamins de
moins en moins les gars qui on est de
moins en moins alors on lui demande de
prendre de plus en plus notre voiture et
on est taxé à mort sur les carburants
dont revêtent on est otages
c'est une prise de c'est du racket de la
part de l'état il y en a marre de ce
racket et c'est le pas de calais un
sentiment d'abandon que le démographe
hervé le bras a constaté dans le profil
qu'il dresse les manifestants un
mal-être des régions éloignées que le
président macron ils le gouvernement
n'ont pas compris au départ dit il comme
le gouvernement ne comprend pas la manif
les manifestations se durcissent ça
devient une sorte de deux pôles
d'agrégation de au fond tous les
problèmes de la société française c'est
donc le pouvoir d'achat c'est les
retraites il n'y a pas eu d'idées
directrices et pour que à une révolte
réussisse il faut qu'une idée directrice
paris est vite devenu la scène
d'affrontement himidi incendie commerces
saccagés monument défiguré jamais la
ville n'avait connu une telle violence
depuis sa libération
réponse des forces de l'ordre s'est
aussi voulue sans précédent la seule
chose qu'on a pu recevoir de l'état
c'est une répression politique
et puis une violence policière macron a
sorti des miettes parce qu'il ya eu de
la casse matérielle
trop peu trop tard vous diront léger
légende qui s'accroche malgré un
essoufflement du mouvement au printemps
dernier emmanuel macron a bien fini par
changer de ton et annoncé l'équivalent
de 25 milliards de dollars canadiens en
mesures diverses dont l'élimination de
la fameuse taxe sur les carburants
moi je rencontre plein de gens qui en
ont marre des plus à l'écouté est allé à
l'hôpital et je veux banaliser un contre
la pauvreté chez corinne insiste mais
elle ne croit pas avoir réussi à ouvrir
une brèche dans le mur d'opposition que
lui offre cette dame visiblement excédé
au jour le jour
ce samedi 16 novembre les gilets jaunes
s'organise sur les réseaux sociaux les
appels à la manifestation à paris et
partout en province se multiplient c'est
de loin dans la capitale que l'on
souhaite souligner ce premier
anniversaire avec le plus de fracas ici
marie-eve bédard radio canada ac en
normandie